and we begin with sad news eddie van
halen has passed away
after a 20-year battle with throat
cancer
[Music]
eddie's son with valerie bertinelli
confirmed the news saying
my heart is broken and i don't think
i'll ever fully recover from this
loss
[Music]
once a heavy smoker and drug user as a
result of the cancer
he had surgery to remove a third of his
tongue get on your feet for the mighty
van halen
[Applause]
the band sold more than 80 million
albums eddie was the league guitar
player his brother alex the drummer
[Music]
eddie married one day at a time star
valerie bertinelli in 1981
e.t visited the two at their la home
when they were newlyweds
i've never met anybody as honest as ever
gets me in a lot of trouble
guys actually just saying the truth to
people at the wrong time
the bad boy rocker and america's tv
sweetheart were married for 26 years
they divorced in 2007 but remained
friendly valerie was a guest
when eddie married his second wife janie
in 2009
[Music]
in recent years eddie's son wolfie
joined van halen as the bass player
and made an appearance with the band on
jimmy kimmel live
born in the netherlands eddie said music
was always part of his life
even on the nine-day boat trip from
holland to new york yeah
my father was in the band on the boat
and my brother and i also played
piano during intermission so my whole
life has been music
i could not imagine anything else
of course our thoughts and prayers go
out to eddie's family his former
bandmate sammy hagar tweeted
heartbroken and speechless my love to
the family
you